[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Conan O'Brien here is my video blog
and just chillin just chillaxing and
hanging out just thinking about what's
cool these days then the most recent
episode of Breaking Bad was just crazy
it it really messed me up
I said meth instead of messed up anyway
you can use that if you want dinosaurs
dinosaurs are making a big comeback
Jurassic Park 4 people are talking about
that's coming out and they're gonna put
Dinobots in the new Transformers movie
so dinosaurs are everywhere so I thought
I'd do a segment called if famous people
were dinosaurs
if famous people were dinosaurs here's
Antonio Banderas Oris right
here's michael cera top this is the Lucy
Raptor and Padma the Lakshmi Raptor and
this is George Stephanopoulos he just
sounds like a dinosaur okay that was a
famous people were dinosaur famous
people we're dinosaurs this next segment
is called spot the Guzman spider :
spot the Guzman spider : this is where I
study photographs and try to find the
actor Luis Guzman in them this is the
Vatican pretty big shot I don't know if
he's there if you look really closely
you can see there he is right there's
Guzman right there yeah this is the
Serengeti it's beautiful is a lot going
on there where is he
this last one is tricky because there
are actually two goos months okay
there's actually a guy wearing a shirt
it has Louie's ghostly but then he's
also check it out he's in the water yeah
now it's time for scary animals with
googly eyes scary animals with googly
eyes there's a mountain lion right here
there's a snake right here here's an an
eel eel
here's a bat right here and here's
Michaels Sarah tops with googly eyes
[Applause]
thanks for watching my video blog